ask me would you shut up Katie do ba is
back girl today
do your bad a voice Katie like weren't
Sims and trying to be tough not the best
one bisexuals they get the best of both
worlds but holes from guys vaginas from
girls maybe a bubble from the girls are
down for it but nowadays it just seems
to be a porn thing I don't really see a
lot of girls I know I've tried it don't
even like it that is what happened look
guys I know some year ago
Ryan's an idiot yeah they're gonna be
like that girl's hot and cute maybe some
of your hesitations yeah maybe they'll
call you in slowly part strand by Kurt
strand will just wrap you in the warm
embrace of indie art like we brought the
right amount of leg yeah yeah do you
think you had enough sex jokes I don't
think that feel that rock solid rock
solid yeah that hurt don't touch me
again like that now that's so weird that
you have anything for muscles I have a
some one thing my girlfriend is really
disappointing me and she'll take that as
a compliment I could go for tea tomorrow
the first look I believe this is a CW
show and if I'm not mistaken legends of
tomorrow is actually about many of the
gods from like you know weirdness the
log like like Sheba okay coming
and they so different origins of gods
come yeah they come together but that's
what it is they come together they come
together so the Buckeye is there like
that should live the weirdest yes and
make a better the makeup either there
you go yo yo huh your son of a [ __ ]
show that to me was a good button to end
on I was like yeah he's saying and my
girlfriend's does the same exact thing
about powers you must expose right
limits if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Katie Dubois
channel the Katie Du Bois channel and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine because we can get
money with product placements with
enough followers
Katie in a bikini you started off
product placement she's holding
fifty-fifty if you're there I want I
want your teeth both of the other great
weight loss results yeah you just poop
out a lot of things and you get thin and
I like pooping
I like pooping gating do these get the
best script ideas when you're pooping
you know whatever works 50 hey guys yeah
laughs remember you're a woman all right
I mean you Chris Pratt's three phases of
Jurassic world acting just like most of
your videos a bit of my own and O'Brien
Katie would you sleep with Chris breath
yeah yeah I think no like embarrassing
no really there's like nothing a ban sir
no really strange I would call me no
he's married
you were just not the woman I know you
after we go in there I'm pretty sure
your sevens lost the [ __ ] okay yeah
that's really the underlying feelings
behind all this sexual animal instincts
okay yeah sure that's what the film is
really exploring do you remember when
AHA when he said you may be some kind of
hero and I said you already are cap yeah
that was the best part of the reaction
that was the best part of the react are
we going over our reactions yeah I'd
rather review our reaction and then
review the trailer okay I thought you
did a nice job yeah those were really
into it yeah
I was really letting my guard down
letting myself feel like this cheesy
emotion yeah it was good feel good
Avengers jokes are so funny he's got
damn phone it's your goddamn phone
answer it correct
no it's factual she will actually go
upside down and then stick her tongue
out then bite her tongue and then roll
it do I get to sexualize you know that's
an affray lady I have a little
girlfriend yeah boy proven Marcus Lumi
you're a good guy you are not a [ __ ]
maneuver for reading that they had to
tone it down in the US and UK like oh my
god what would the original look like it
looked fun though when I was watching
the footage I kinda wanna play you
haven't played that I haven't personally
played manhunt - I've seen footage
before
[Music]
oh yeah like respite or something yeah I
wish it was like for a different video
the top ten film one you know gross
military cuz you know like nothing
maybe I should see that you like your
bodies oh yeah I can I see one thing you
could say shoot I'm shooting next week
so I've been in pre-production yay
cuz new videos soon I'm shooting a film
next week
oh I'm producing oh yeah so I'm sure
it's gonna be a great film hey guys I'm
Ryan Wright and I'm Katie du Bois so
today we're gonna check out a video from
alltime10s
called ten disgusting things about the
porn industry now if anyone knows Katie
uh you know she loves porn she loves a
good porn out everything DP gang bang
bang gang bang green pie gangbang she
does a lot of gangbang kind of porn not
personally but she's into it anyway
let's watch this I like to let the
guests speak in the intros from another
country or not I'm from America so yeah
there's the moral standpoint but even a
legal standpoint it's illegal for me to
be driven off of that right yeah even
with girls from other countries one sec
camera cut I'm from America so yeah
there's the moral standpoint but even a
legal standpoint it's illegal for me to
drop that right yeah even with girls
from other countries I shouldn't watch
that right right don't get arrested oh
no no the moral the moral that's right
there's a guideline here who freaks me
out
no no Boop I don't even like it when
there's like
who've seen the toilet that I know a
girl left there bothers me Veronica
knows that when she goes poop she's a
[ __ ] ninja about it I don't know I
never know she times herself to longer
than two minutes are taking a [ __ ]
that's what I learned
huh
hearing the fact that like some men's
penises actually get fractured that's
very scary any interest I had everyone
before just went out the window
right from there oh oh I'm performing
yourself like being pornstar Yeah right
you know if things don't work out no I
know
yeah that does not sound good to me I
can recognize my family members is being
attractive but I have no desire actual
situation oh yeah there are some sexy
ass hot-ass poor family members but my
drive today no talk about booth booth
ladies if you're watching plastic
surgery is the best way to improve
yourself
men are perfect women are flawed that is
a it's Old Testament what what please
provide a quote this you know I'm doing
right now I'm coming for you I am
literally for you right now
secreting semen I'm giving you some
space
thank you Wow you deserve the Ryan right
semen the rat semen yes I always wait
because I can never see your reaction as
you're always off to the side
yeah you're inside everything you can
imagine if they did this like in the
oculus rift that's like you put on those
like that giant thing yeah yeah three
six years old experience tell people
they should come up with that I heard
they have it for color now you know that
there's oculus rift porn this is why you
really feel like you're having sex with
the person that seems like a natural
progression yeah Katie was born I don't
see like a penis get ripped off
really I want to see like someone like
carve out the buckle first-person point
of view I want to see this guy eat up a
giant you're mad at me go like you don't
want to see that these are all the
things I don't want to fantasized about
no this is what Aladeen again it's a
porn in early age we talked about this
Katie you want to become a kids don't do
this you could check out the TV's
channel on the Katie dupois channel
starring Katie you walk
goodbye is it okay to write this whole
time yeah but I've just been walking you
know I need to follow me on Facebook
Instagram Twitter buy a periscope
she's a Twitter and Instagram yep that's
far she goes
[Music]
I only do that when the cameras when the
cameras rolling is the only time I put
you oh stop stabbing me with your
imaginary right down
I believe it when it happens let's see
if I can make a funny about you
Wow there is a more of a side to you
than the average person your age that's
okay I know what it's like to be more
sighs sighs more down there the penis'
[Music]
he's one talking out of it man [ __ ] you
guys both of you
Oh key I said don't do that there's very
few compilations I watch what's my like
did you get radians or you know it's -
give me some compilations doubling old
compilations I have to jerk off of the
double anal ones they're just a little
bit more interesting because I
consistently not make you [ __ ]
anyway animal thug life compilation here
we go geez I've done that before
something that many of times I usually
throw my urine don't ask me how I do it
you see this there's a perfect cupping
of hands right here no urine will leak
through these fingers how do you it
doesn't really get unit there's no
projectile nature
we listened to what was a peeper no
reaction here we go yeah there's nowhere
near yes yeah there was something before
that car crash that really triggered
these actions no this thing our formulas
I go really
you look grossed out and then decide to
go along I mean it was like a woman in a
bikini with big tits and she came out of
the car alive no damage I know this is
called reality fair the progeny
prostitutes in my life escape I need to
try to kill them they saw that picture
of my penis just what and I would run
no it was a bad picture that day it was
awful
where's the black prostitutes there'd
been number one process you didn't like
went there because I'm not racist I want
a black prostitute I don't know being
fascinated with violence I have a
certain agent we all sort of go like I
was fascinated with the Titanic yeah
everyone died and it's like I think you
kind of have to learn how to process
stuff unlike mass death and like
horrifying circumstances yeah but there
are people most people learn how to
process that just denial is the only way
to truly do uncharged dinosaur yeah
blonde on the cage blah channel get yo
dick to blood that sounds like I'm
telling people to jerk off to you she
doesn't like penis hello guys Ryan the
right here
I'm Katie do what this was over two
hours nice it's amazing Katie yeah yeah
it's a personal vibe on this channel and
they always shoot them like handheld and
I want to like tear apart bodies
all right so echo ragga
you know the great one if theory
actually came from Russia from the
stanislavski's system who is the
godfather of method acting
he was the know you're really proud of
this fact what if into the culture
before that it was all like in the club
we're gestures on this stage but after
what if people actually started saying
okay like let's make movies let's make
here like real life we're listening face
more you know
oh crap crap that's not what you bring
on the show no more cleavage is what's
necessary yeah how many show they I'm
ripping my balls off yeah that was great
Catherine do blah yeah what's your
Twitter I never find you Katie Dubois
Katie a YouTube channel I'm really
trying to get it places you want to
guess start and that's all right Katie
and every other female will find you you
give me so much shade I think we're
friends though do you want to know how
to get girls it's this simple
hey I have a youtube channel I'm really
trying to get it places you want to
guess start and that's how Ryan met
Katie that's what you mean by that net
not like and it's not why I'd like to
every other female I know it's a
networking opportunity and then somehow
you just come in something to do YouTube
and then you just keep doing more
YouTube videos ago
Oh
do you wanna play yes I'm with you on
that come on yes and for Backson Katie
and I are gonna try to just talk to you
guys so the attack directly in the
camera I know even love it when
youtubers do that even while we're in
conversation trying to just look at
anything your hair changes every
conversation she guest-starred in a web
series that just launched on YouTube
call me you him and she's in three of
the episodes
it's a funny show it starts three black
guys which is cool it's really cool yeah
right that's your one handsome devil
your one handsome devil there's a
problem though my girlfriend likes
Hispanic guys a lot I mean that's her
favorite thing I don't know why I'm
assuming that but that's that's her
thing and you look like a really
good-looking Hispanic guy my
girlfriend's half Mexican eat so we're
gonna be attracted to each other what I
want to do both you know chances of that
happening
not likely she's not down for something
like that so she's gonna leave me for
you I don't know if I could have me on
this channel and we good sorry
and trying not to jump to conclusions
these days but I can't help her just
remember what we talked about I was like
a really sad grounded I want funniest
kid in junior high but that's besides
the point I'm asked at all my hilarious
humor with you know I messed the
depression so in school I would say yeah
when I'm feeling down i watch Conan
O'Brien I'll call it my combs own
medication shooting impression my KD
impression I come across appropriate but
really I have a dirty mind oh it's the
third one right
I like to be a little mysterious
unsettled quirky it would be fun to be
on one of those games I'm one of the
celebrity if it was one of the shows
where you can do games like balances
games yeah yeah you know competitions I
feel like that would be fun
okay that's fair good point that'd be
fun I don't know I said that's fair
so Thomas debating with you Katie dupois
has a Facebook Instagram maybe someday
he'll do something with her YouTube
channel who knows and there's a show
where she guest-starred in three of the
episodes me you him just launched its on
YouTube you can go check it out it's
primarily a black cast I'm trying to get
at least one or two of them on the
channel I have nothing against bringing
three black folks on it's just one or
two just to introduce some guests you
know maybe I like oh how come when I
talk about black people
I just immediately come across races so
it's like my worry is don't sound racist
and then I end up saying things that
make me sound racist yeah well that's a
spoof the last one dress okay good
intelligence to be a boy to be a boy am
i right around one day I realize I can
make dick jokes for a living
[Music]
furniture she's like Veronica manatee
handle anything I've broken many other
mass I'm broke her laptop on it audio
does not work on the computer anymore
very hard for her to edit like trying so
hard to stay with you I'm not sure about
how to contribute I'm Veronica never
leaves me cuz I'm your old one Katie's
on social networks such as the Facebook
Kathryn Duvall
Twitter's and the instagrams the
youtubes and she guest-starred in a web
series that just launched it's on
YouTube called me you and him which
ironically is primarily a black cast
characters from the board if you guys
watch the board on my channel so you'll
find them you have series also on my
channel so there's some white people
there is there's a great it's a very
diverse and fun now by diversity mean
like black and white and that's it
30 agents Hispanics yeah are all those
things yeah things they're people
[Music]
[Music]
there's the video oh my god so sweet of
you to me oh yeah you're the first one
who gets a compilation video don't make
jokes guys about the compilation video
people might say compilation but that's
not what it is it's a compilation video
of love not of coma shots
I like my girlfriend just has no Mackay
yeah I'm really gonna miss you and
anything about this channel you're gonna
miss yeah I'm gonna miss getting to come
here and be goofy you guys understand
I'm like really bummed watching that was
so fun like I guess I was sorting over
two hours of footage oh my god so sweet
and I had to just do the things I was
like alright I'm just gonna put in here
what makes me laugh and I got a bit like
you told me 12 o'clock and I was like
panicking about not but but now you can
come to New York and I'll try and like
edge into some youtube in New York and
you just have an expanded yeah it's the
next cinematic universe um you know who
you should meet yep Tyrone Magnus Tyrone
Magnus I would be super excited to meet
him did she go ahead for the same
reasons I'm thinking no are you sure
have you ever dated a big black guy like
muscles right I remember that from the
video yeah muscles big black guy right
comedy reactions come on reactions I
know all these things that I like well
it's nothing work definitely worth a
meet and greet
I got you know you should totally meet
Tyrone I'll introduce you guys fun
you'll love you good he will make love
to you in that beautiful black voice of
his mm-hmm um so you told me that you
had this lovely video you said you had
something for me so I grabbed something
for you it just really something just a
smidgen something a memorabilia of sorts
it's a goofy present
I like goofy
it's sweet because I think I'm I'm a
sweet white girl I love it
I'm getting lightheaded from laughing
that's so cool how do you peel it it's
you have to really well are you are you
gonna eat this cuz you you got to commit
to eating it okay we're in baby you want
to get out on this I in lollipop all
right you get one side if this was a
vagina you really get in her job right
wait wait wait do they have flavors wait
red all right that was red I can't tell
I can't tell the difference between any
of them they all taste the same I think
they're all this thing I think it's just
sugar it any mark worth it okay they're
all taste the same yep yep you look
amazing with that would you thank you
yeah I kind of don't want to end the
video even though I know I should just
because I'm gonna have to say goodbye to
you
well I can't then I get play with his
lollipop once you leave I know I don't
know how you can keep it so like once
you start you you might have to commit
or oh you know I thought you could just
put some saran wrap around it for
intermediary times well because of my
penis size I have very large condoms I
could wrap around this perfect no cuz
there's like powdery on the inside and
like Ruby on the flavor that'll add to
the lollipop
uh-huh you've never like done fellatio
with a condom over it you're telling me
that that's like a tasty thing yeah no
okay no I've never liked a condom I've
ever like licked a powdery sticky rubber
band